hey how's it going
today we are going to Photoshop in real
life a lot of you bros suggested we're
gonna do pokemons
I don't know I don't know how to do that
I really don't a lot of you bros are
giving me a lot of credit for for being
good at Photoshop but really I'm not I'm
not that good but I'm gonna try and
we'll see how it goes
obviously we're gonna start with big a
big guy okay
so there's already a couple a couple of
ones not that great if I may say so
myself
and technically Pikachu is Mouse Pokemon
peasants let's get started shall we
I choose You Pikachu all right so we
want this to become this let's begin
with the body shape
that's such a great looking Pikachu
let's make the feet a little smaller
shall we
beautiful let's move on to the head I'm
excited about this where do you begin
the head is beautiful hmm should not be
making noises like that let's make the
eyes baby
how I does a [ __ ] hell demon rat I
don't know it's so tiny little dot the
mouth huh we're gonna transplant the
mouth doctor pills it's a very
complicated procedure
how I pick at your Chad sorry I'm sorry
I haven't I have a serious issue it's
not funny
alright let's move on and make pickup
pickup demon pika some ears whatever the
[ __ ] those things are
Wow I like it sir cute how I let's do
that [ __ ] hands and then I don't know
man nice step rows for our pig a pig pig
pig ain't no pic a [ __ ] without no pick
a kill
oh my god let's get me so this is our
rat tail look like this is our Pikachu
tail look like what the [ __ ]
I forgot the cheeks how could I forget
to poke at bigger cheeks
poke a pig poke poke
I kind of like that it's white I don't
know why so I'm just gonna go with a
white picket you what are you what are
your breasts thing before pick at you
five after pick at your five pick up big
let's do a dig light I mean they must be
a mole right right giggling doesn't have
any arms let's get rid of those alright
now we need this to be shaped like the
tip of a penis Oh Pokemon how much I
love you and your sexual references
nice it's a furry penis what do you do
today I've created a fur a penis baby
let's get that cow I know it's in there
I don't I I don't know what I'm doing
either don't worry about it
all right let's fix that cute ass
[ __ ] ass baby is even a vice as
moles have eyes but they blind oh god
what is that
vagina balls are they're blind aren't
they yep
that looks good yep
there you go a big big light so good I'm
so proud of that one okay let's finish
this [ __ ] off with a pigeon Pidgey is
that it so everyone says it's based off
a pigeon the pigeon don't look like [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] piggy how the hell how to
how to hell
first of all let's fatten that [ __ ] up
baby yes the wings kind of in here
let's make the feet [ __ ] giant as
[ __ ] boom done
okay I don't know why the eyes are so
[ __ ] big like they give this keep
playing Wonder Woman laughs man this
bird looks cool it [ __ ] look at that
need another mouse transplant or you
talking to [ __ ] pimp as pigeon Wow
let's color that [ __ ]
okay I learned something here today I
don't know how to call her in Photoshop
because that's that's not good enough
alright but I like that I like the
original one so we're gonna we're gonna
go with that how about that
let's look back at what we've done let's
not look back at what we done I like to
forget you I can put my name on that one
how about that browse if you enjoyed
these real-life videos hit that like
button recommend me what else you want
to see become in real life anime
cartoons your mom thank you for watching
and I'll see you bros and the next one
stay awesome rapid I have a bucket I
want to ride the my ah yeah yeah baby
what's up I'm sorry I'm sorry what is it